Itadakimasu!
I want soba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba.
I want soba - ba kudasai, so gimme soba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba - ba.
I need soba - ba onegai.
I want saba.
I want buri.
I want aji swimming inside of me.
I boogie with mugi, shimmy with sashimi,...
...cha-cha with chuka, gyoza gimme gimme.
I polka with piman, wiggle with natto.
For all of these gifts, I say arigato!
I want tofu from Chofu.
You know that I'd go for a bowlful right now, so gimme tofu from Chofu,...
...you know that I'd go for a bowlful right now.
I want ebi.
I want ika.
I want tako swimming inside of me.
Fabulous fugu, beautiful bancha, dazzling daikon, wasabi I want ya.
Elegant ebi, marvelous miso, glamorous gobo, how could it be so good, good, good, good.
Japanese food, food, food, food; pickled or stewed, stewed, stewed, stewed,...
...makes me feel good!
I used to think that I was rude to vocally enjoy my food,...
...but over here a stylish dude can slurp, slurp, slurp, with attitude.
So now I'm in a happy mood, glad that I'm eating Japanese food, Japanese food.
It sure tastes good, Japanese food.